MALE SPEAKER: I'm pleased
to welcome Matt Richtel back
to Google.
I say, welcome
back, since he spoke
at one of the first authors
at Google events in San
Francisco about seven
years ago, so we're
delighted to have him back.
So Matt, as many of you know,
is investigative journalist
for the "New York Times."
He won a Pulitzer Prize in
2010 for his work on the issue
of distracted driving.
And today, he's here to
talk about his new book.
It's actually not that new,
but it's new on paperback,
I believe-- "A
Deadly Wandering."
We'll do about 20-ish minutes
of a presentation by Matt.
We'll do some question
and answer after that.
And there are books in
the back for those of you
who are here live.
Please join me in
welcoming Matt.
[APPLAUSE]
MATT RICHTEL: Thank you, Such.
So, a quick preface-- you
mentioned the first book.
The first book came out in 2007.
And just a brief anecdote about
it-- it was called "Hooked."
And a friend of mine,
actually right around here,
went to Barnes &
Noble and saw it
on the front table,
sandwiched between a book
by Martha Stewart and
a Superman anthology.
And he was very fired up.
This here's his buddy
Matt's first book.
He takes out his camera phone,
goes to take a picture of it.
And the clerk comes from behind
the desk and says, "Excuse me,
sir.
What are you doing?"
He says, "I'm taking a
picture of my friend's book."
And the guy goes, "You've
got to be kidding me.
You're friends with
Martha Stewart?"
Quick question, for those
of you live-- anybody
currently in a bad
relationship, or have you
been in a bad relationship?
Show of hands-- one, two, three.
Are you in a bad
relationship with someone
you're sitting next
to you right now?
No, OK.
I am going to propose
today that you
are in a bad relationship
with your phone.
It's a lot like
your relationship
with your high school
sweetheart, where
it seemed really good.
But in retrospect, she
or he was a lot more
demanding than you
realized at the time.
You didn't quite fit right.
Maybe you needed some time apart
to get your perspective back.
This is going to be a little
bit about the question,
is technology addictive?
I'm going to get to an
answer to that question.
It's going to go far
afield of the car, which
is where my research
started in the series
that Such alluded
to, "Previously
Undistracted Driving."
I'm going to talk about your
relationship to your phone
broadly.
There are some really, really
remarkable research right now.
I think this is a great
audience to be discussing it
in front of.
But that said,
I'm going to start
by just telling you
I about something
that happened in a car.
Because it is the narrative
throughline of the book,
"A Deadly Wandering."
It happened on the last
day of summer in 2006.
And I want you to meet this guy.
His name is Reggie Shaw.
He looks and is exactly
what you see here.
He is the veritable
All-American kid.
And when I say that, he is the
good kind of All-American kid,
like the nice guy.
You know, like, A minuses
and B pluses, not A pluses.
And he played on
the basketball team,
but was the nice kind of jock.
And he really just
wanted to fall in love.
And he really, really wanted
to go on an LDS mission.
He lived in the
northernmost county of Utah.
And he was on his mission
in the summer, the beginning
of the summer of
2006 when he felt
duty-bound to admit
something to the president
of the missionary
training center.
He'd had premarital sex, and
he had not come clean about it
to his bishop and had not
done the spiritual work.
And in the LDS
community, that's not OK.
And he knew that he would
come home humiliated
in front of his community.
Why do I tell you this seemingly
startling and even intimate
detail about this young man who
was 19 years old at the time?
Because this is a guy
who's a good, good guy.
He's also a guy who might
not tell the truth if he were
pressed, like telling
his ward bishop that he
hadn't had premarital sex when
he had, to go on his mission.
And on the last day of summer
2006, it was September.
He was back from
his Mormon mission
doing the spiritual
work to go back again.
And he was driving at
6:30 in the morning
on a mountainous road through
the northernmost county
of Utah.
He was going 55 miles an hour.
Despite the fact that it
was the last day of summer,
it was starting to
rain freezing rain.
And there was a car
behind him, a truck
carrying two tons of horseshoes
and horseshoe-making equipment.
You guys, this is a
missile at highway speeds.
And the driver of it is
noticing that Reggie,
our All-American young man,
is occasionally swerving
across the yellow divider.
Coming the other
direction this morning
are these two guys, Jim
Furfaro and Keith O'Dell.
Jim has the beard.
They are-- sincerely,
not cliched--
they are rocket scientists.
They are building the booster
for the next space shuttle.
They're commuting to work.
The guy without the beard,
Keith, is known as the genius.
He's won the
highest safety award
from NASA, the Snoopy award.
And the next time Reggie
crosses the yellow divider,
he clips the Saturn
these two guys are in,
it spins across the road,
it is nailed broadside
by the guy carrying
two tons of horseshoes
and horseshoe-making equipment.
The rocket scientists
are dead on impact.
I hope you'll pick up the
book, "A Deadly Wandering."
I don't want to circumvent it.
I don't want to undermine
the drama of it.
But what ensues is a
remarkable, seminal mystery,
an investigation.
But it is ultimately determined
over Reggie's denials
that he has texted 11
times in the minutes
and seconds around the crash.
And it leads to the
first criminal trial,
certainly in Utah,
maybe in the US.
So since that time,
I've told you today
that we're not going to
be talking exclusively
about texting and driving.
But I want to frame
the conversation
around that for this
very significant reason.
If we can text and
drive in the car
when we're moving, when lives
are at stake, when we know it,
what does it say about our
behavior the rest of the time?
So I want to tell
you something here.
I want to tell you about a
remarkable statistical gap.
Currently, these figures are
from-- forgive me the source.
It's the AAA Foundation for
Highway Safety, Traffic Safety.
84.4% of us say
texting and driving
is completely unacceptable.
36% say they read or
text while driving.
27% have sent one.
That's 2014, not a good gap
between what we say we believe
and how we behave--
not the startling part.
Here's the startling part.
That behavior's up since 2012.
All the PSAs, the public
service number announcements,
all the laws passed-- the
gap is widening between what
we say is wrong and what we do.
You guys want to hear
the gap that sounds
most similar to that to me?
Anybody want to
take a guess that's
here where there's such a gap
between what we say we believe
and how we behave?
Not drinking-- we're
better at that.
What else?
Smoking-- every smoker
says, this is not exactly
a great idea for my health.
They do it anyway.
Why do they do it?
It's addictive.
We're going to get to the
question of whether it's
addictive today.
But to get there, I want
to tell you a little bit
about your brain on computers,
about your relationship
with computers.
And to do so, I'm
going to ask you
to travel back with me in time.
We're going to do a
little neuroscience.
I want you picture
yourself as a cave person.
So the way to do
this is very simple.
Picture yourself, but hairier.
So there you are.
This is your forbear
tending to a fire, eons ago.
Lion comes up from
behind, or better yet,
let's use this example.
The person tending
to the fire gets
a tap on his or her
shoulder from behind.
Can the person ignore
the tap on the shoulder?
No way.
I'm getting nodded heads.
You guys hopefully
live streaming
are nodding your heads.
Why can't you ignore the tap?
Anyone?
You have no idea if it's
opportunity or threat.
And maybe the
threat is profound.
Maybe it's someone with a spear.
Maybe the opportunity
is a potential mate.
Maybe it's someone with food.
Maybe they're
warning of a volcano.
In the car, here's the analog.
Driving, phone
rings, proverbial tap
on the shoulder from anyone,
anywhere in the world.
Now, I want to tell you what's
happening inside your brain
at that moment.
When tending to a
fire, when driving,
you are using this part
of your brain-- prefrontal
cortex, frontal lobe.
I know you guys know this.
I'll just go over it briefly.
It is the thing that
makes us the most
human, the most evolved.
You can see by comparison
other creatures.
This is your executive
control center.
It dictates attention,
focus, decision-making,
go down the list.
Art, architecture,
civilization-- all that we are,
higher levels, is
involved with that.
And it's involved with
driving-- attending to the road,
attending to the fire,
like the cave person.
But when the signal
comes, the tap
on the shoulder, very roughly,
the signal comes from here.
This is much more shared
with these other animals.
The reptilian part of the
brain, ancient, comes up
and it says, when you have
a roar of the lion-- lion!
Run or die.
Someone with a spear--
turn around or die.
When you're in the car
and the phone rings,
maybe it's your boss.
Maybe it's your mate.
Maybe it's a prince from
Nigeria who needs money.
You take my point.
It, in effect, hijacks
that part of your brain.
It is a basic, primitive thing.
Put this down in your brains
as point number one, evidence
point number one, of the ways
in which your phone begins
to hijack this
part of your brain,
even against your professed
will or your understanding
of what's dangerous.
Just a quick question that
someone will invariably have.
Such, will you come
up here for a second?
OK, Such.
People will ask, why can't
I attend to both things
at once, two streams
of information?
Let's just go through
this exercise.
Recite A to I as
fast as you can.
MALE SPEAKER: A,B,
C,D, E, F, G, H, I.
MATT RICHTEL: Well done.
That is a Googler for you.
Now, 1 to 9.
MALE SPEAKER: 1, 2,
3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9.
MATT RICHTEL: Wow.
Now, alternate.
A, 1, B, 2.
MALE SPEAKER: A, 1, B,
2, C, 3, D, 4, E, 5.
MATT RICHTEL: You may sit.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you, Matt.
MATT RICHTEL: So look-- for
those of you keeping score
at home or at your desks, you
see how much longer it takes.
That is an act of switching
information streams.
It's called switching
costs, switching tasks.
You guys know these terms.
You've heard of them.
You're at your desk,
you're in your car--
to switch among streams
of information takes
profound, profound
neurological energy,
even when it's something
as simple as that.
So now, checklist--
tap on the shoulder,
you don't know what it is.
Now I've shown you that you
can't do two things at once.
We're going to speed
ahead a little bit.
This is the cost, by
the way, of ignoring
the tap on the shoulder.
This is called doing a
PowerPoint when you have
too much time on your hands.
You can find anything on
the fancy internet machine.
OK, look-- it's not just
information that's coming in.
It's social information.
Social information also
is critical at an adaptive
or even primitive DNA level.
Let me just illustrate
by way of an example.
Let's go back to our forbear
in front of the fire.
If my buddy in front of the
fire puts his hand in the fire
and gets it burned and gets
blisters and gets an infection
and dies and cannot tell me
that that's what's happened,
I then have to put my
hand in the fire and I die
and the species goes with it.
Social information is critical.
There's a question as to whether
it's hardwired into our DNA
or primitively adapted.
But in any case, we're talking
about the way back machine,
right?
So now it's not just
a tap on the shoulder.
It's social
information that we're
programmed to respond
to-- one and two-- three.
One of my favorite
pieces of trivia
in reading this book--
you would say to yourself,
if most of the stuff
I get on my phone
is irrelevant and
even counterproductive
spam, if you will, wouldn't
that condition me not
to look at my device?
Anyone want to take
a stab at this one?
Not you, because you've read
the book, and can, by the way,
can vouch for the book.
MALE SPEAKER: Absolutely.
Absolutely.
I'll do that later.
MATT RICHTEL: An
astounding review.
Get them while they're hot.
Here's why.
When you get irrelevant
information all the time,
you never know when the
good piece of information
is going to come.
This is the same
thing that makes--
what's the gizmo
where we pull the--
AUDIENCE: Slot machine.
MATT RICHTEL: Thank
you very much.
But I'll make it a
more profound example.
B.F. Skinner, you
guys have probably
heard of-- Skinnerian
psychology,
behavioral psychology.
Way back when, he
does an experiment.
Rat in a cage-- there's
that lever in the cage.
Rat doesn't know which press
of the lever will bring food.
So the rat hits the
lever all the time.
It's called intermittent
reinforcement,
one of the most powerful
lures in psychology,
if you'll forgive the
comparison of us to rodents.
You see where I'm
going with this.
Intermittent reinforcement--
will press the lever for food,
will hit mouse for food--
mouse, rodent, rat.
Now I've gone on a
terrible tangent.
The lure of worthless data.
So the fact that
it's irrelevant data
doesn't make this
less appealing.
It can make it more appealing.
Tap on the shoulder--
a mechanical activity
of survival.
Social information-- the
lure of worthless activity.
OK, this one's pretty
early in the research.
But you guys are familiar
with or you've heard
of the neurochemical dopamine?
It's the neurochemical involved
in reward structures involved
in drugs, narcotics.
There is some early research
that suggests, shows,
that when you interact
with your device,
in particular video games, you
get a little burst of dopamine.
So here's how the
theory goes on.
And I think we're
still working this out.
We, I mean, in
society-- I don't want
to go beyond where
the research is.
But there's some really
powerful early research
that essentially says,
leads to a hypothesis,
that you get a little
burst of dopamine
when you interact
with your device.
Do you guys know this feeling?
A little surge, a
little excitement.
You get a little
burst of dopamine.
And then in its
absence, you feel bored.
So what do you do?
You seek it out.
This is a heavy-duty
reinforcement cycle
at the neurochemical level.
And this is a quote from the guy
who teaches internet addiction.
There's actually a class
at a medical school,
at the University
of Connecticut.
"You see the computer,
it's one trigger.
Then you sit at the
keyboard, it's another.
You push the key,
you get a result.
There's a cascade of dopamine.
It's the big kahuna.
It's in a sense a narcotic."
And I just want to add
one final thing here
when we're adding
up these pieces.
So we've got dopamine,
the tap on the shoulder,
lure of worthless data,
and the one other.
And there's one more
here on neurochemicals.
Harvard researchers have shown
that the sharing of information
releases dopamine--
of social information.
Humans so willingly
self-disclose because doing so
represents an event
with intrinsic value,
in the same way as with primary
awards such as food and sex.
So now it's not
just getting stuff.
It's providing stuff.
I hope at this point in
the conversation you're
beginning to view your device
a little differently than you
may have viewed it previously.
Yes, it is all
the amazing things
that we have come to count on.
It is a communications device.
It is a navigation device.
It is an information device.
This is not a screed
against technology.
It is also something else.
It is an act of
neurochemical activity,
habituation-- maybe
interdependence,
maybe co-dependence.
I want to tell you what
all this adds up to.
I want to give you a theory
that I sort of worked
with scientists and learned from
scientists and added it all up.
I want to draw a comparison to
the industrialization of food.
When food was industrialized,
it was, on the whole,
a remarkable thing.
We tilled the fields.
We got the food where it
needed to go on trucks
and trains-- more calories to
more people, more survival.
No way to argue about that.
But at the same time, as
we industrialized food,
we came up with
incredible processes
for creating food
and calories that
can be so seductive
as to be dangerous.
And I'm thinking of
the vending machine.
I'm thinking-- I don't
want to pick on Doritos,
but that's just the first
thing that comes to mind.
You know, a Dorito
actually has--
it's so tasty because it has a
concentration of sugar and fat
that we crave.
But the thing is,
in the old days,
if you got that concentration
of sugar and fat,
you climbed over a mountain
and went into the cave
and killed the woolly
mammoth with your bare hands.
And by the time you ate
that woolly mammoth,
you sure needed it.
But now you walk
down the hallway
and hit a button for a quarter.
And you've got
sugar and fat that
leads to-- can lead,
in excessive amounts,
to diabetes and obesity.
And we're only
learning now the costs.
Here's the parallel.
There is no doubt that this
technology, this communications
technology, is so
remarkable and amazing
and leads to efficiencies and
the creation of PowerPoints
and talking on FaceTime to
grandparents and loved ones.
Forget it.
We'll be on the moon soon--
I mean, on Mars soon.
We'll be on the moon.
I'm telling you guys.
America is getting to the moon.
And that's my next book.
We will get there.
Or Mars and beyond--
there's no doubt.
But I want you to
begin to think about,
as I have begun to
think about from talking
to these researchers
and I lay out
in this context of this
harrowing accident mystery,
that there is junk
food in our midst.
And unless we are aware of
the way in which this stuff is
playing to us, we
may well get whatever
is the equivalent of obesity and
diabetes, which is distraction.
So "the cell phone
meets a deep need
for social connection with
a greater ease and a greater
potential detriment to
do it in the same way
that a vending machine
that is right down the hall
plays to our need for calories."
This is from a Yale MD and
social media professor.
Let me just end
with one anecdote.
I have a son who's
now almost seven,
but when he was almost two, I
think, or almost three-- this
is not him.
He was at his
grandmother's house.
And I didn't think--
his name's Milo.
I didn't think he
knew that many words.
He just kind of would barely
put sentences together.
And his phone-- I'm starting
the whole presentation over.
His foot hit one of those little
Fisher-Price mobile phones
and it rang.
And he picks it up.
And I was just so
blown away, because I
didn't know he knew these words,
certainly not in this order.
And he picks up the little
phone and he goes, "I'll
call you from a land line."
So let this be our
lesson, occasionally
from the mouth of babes.
I'll call you from a land line.
Let's have a chat.
And incidentally, you
guys, among the things
we can talk about
are practically,
what does this mean
in everyday life?
What are antidotes to it?
Anyway, lots of things.
Go.
MALE SPEAKER: Absolutely.
So you alluded towards
the end to the angle
that I'm most
interested in, which
is the evolutionary angle.
You mentioned junk food.
We've got these powerful
evolutionary cues
for sugars, salts, and fats.
And processed food
plays right into that.
So it occurred to me
while you were speaking,
imagine if people had
jobs where they just
had to eat Doritos all day.
I mean, here at Google,
what would they say?
Stat, we check more email,
like, seven times more email
than the average,
other tech worker?
The number is probably
bigger than that.
It almost feels like we're
paid to eat Doritos all day.
What's a realistic
solution to you?
MATT RICHTEL: Well,
that's a great point
and a great question.
And let me just
address that briefly
in the context of distracted
driving, as we blossom out.
Car issues are not new.
Drunk driving,
seat belts-- we've
worked hard as a society to
come to terms with those issues.
And there are rules
for having them happen.
But in those instances,
it wasn't the case
that there was societal pressure
to say, drink and drive.
And no one ever told
you it was cool not
to wear your seat belt. Maybe
one buddy joked with you,
you were wimpy.
Whatever.
There is now enormous
societal pressure
to stay connected all the time.
And if you start paying
attention to the marketing,
as I've documented some in
my book, some of the ads
essentially say, you are uncool
if you don't have a signal,
even on top of Everest.
Somehow you are less than
if you're not connected.
So it goes beyond you're
habituated at your desk.
You actually are a less than
if you're not connected.
What's my thought about
ways to address it?
I actually think some of
the companies in the Valley
have begun to think about
this, including you guys.
I did a story a
bit about it where
you will encourage
people to disconnect
for the sake of having lucid,
cogent, long-term, creative
thoughts.
It's really, really hard to do.
We were at lunch with a
couple of your colleagues.
And we were talking
about my writing process.
And actually, in
retrospect, I said, well,
I don't do anything special.
I do one thing special.
I turn off my phone.
You cannot get
invested in something.
You're going to say
you can, and you need
those streams of information.
The truth is, what it behaves
as, to a large extent,
is a procrastination device.
When you're in the
middle of something
hard that takes the most
amount of your energy--
will you testify to this?
You're nodding.
You will easily go look at your
phone, because-- so what to do?
You have a lot of self-control.
I don't think your boss needs
to hear from you that quickly.
You tell me.
I mean, reflect with me.
What would happen you were 15
minutes late on a response?
MALE SPEAKER: Interesting.
We can hash this out
right now, can't we?
MATT RICHTEL: Oh, yes,
your boss is here.
MALE SPEAKER: Conveniently.
It's a good question,
I think, for Googlers.
I think it varies team to team.
There are roles where you
are expected to be on call.
There are some more
forward-thinking folks
who won't fire you
if that's the case.
I think it varies.
Would you guys agree?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
It's Google.
It depends.
MALE SPEAKER: It depends.
Dot, dot, dot.
MATT RICHTEL: So I think
one takeaway for me--
I'll speak for me--
is understanding
the habituation that happens
and the feeling of craving that
begins to develop.
Once I begin to see that that
is the better part of my desire
to stay on my device, and
that it's not actually
this desperate need to
hear the next message that
will be the difference
between life and death,
I can draw better lines.
I mean, it's like the first step
is admitting you have a modem.
No, that doesn't
really work anymore.
MALE SPEAKER: So
if I may, I guess
what you're saying-- we talk
about this as an addiction.
And so one common behavior
they say or a sign of am I
an addict or not
is the inability
to set clear boundaries.
You set a line.
You're always crossing it.
So I guess what
you're saying is,
the first step is
just being cognizant.
So if you find yourself
on the top of Everest
and you need to post
that on Instagram,
or if the phone dings in
the car and all of a sudden
the road doesn't matter.
You have to know
what that ding is,
you can catch yourself,
and then think,
do I really want
to be this person?
MATT RICHTEL: Would it be OK
to throw in a fun study here
to reinforce the risks?
Will you guys endure the
chocolate cake study?
I'll do it quick.
I'll make it simple.
Researchers do this study where
they have some people in a room
and they ask them, do you want
the chocolate cake or the fruit
cocktail snack?
But some of the people
going into the experiment,
into the room, have to
remember a string of numbers.
To a very statistically
significant degree,
the people who have to
remember the numbers
choose the chocolate cake.
What do the researchers infer?
They infer that when you're
juggling information,
you make a very
different decision.
In fact, you make a, quote,
unquote, "less good" decision.
So what does this
have to do with what
we're talking about here?
There's other research to
back this up, a bunch of it
in the book.
But when you are juggling
information on your phone
or when you're
juggling two streams
or keeping a lot in
your head, you actually
can't make a good decision
about whether to even use
your device.
It's one of the interesting
things about the car example.
When you're driving, you're
consuming some of this.
It makes it hard to
decide, should you
even answer the phone?
There's a bunch of
research in here
that will show you
are more creative,
you have better memory, you
are better able to learn,
when you're not
using the device.
Again, not a screed
against technology,
but a clarion call,
if you will, to say,
I can use this to my advantage.
And I could be
the most powerful.
It can be a bit of
kryptonite if I don't.
MALE SPEAKER: Very cool.
So let's talk back in the
lens of addiction again.
You also hear that people who
are suffering from an addiction
find that moment of clarity when
they kind of hit rock bottom.
And so I know you're a parent.
There's parents in the audience.
Imagine if you're
trying to get your kid
to stop texting and driving or
to put the phone in the trunk
while they're driving.
Do you find that folks with
this sort of tech addiction
need to have that
moment of clarity?
Do you hear people
talking about,
I was on the top of Everest
and I needed my phone out.
That's when I realized
I had a problem.
Because I don't hear those
stories about tech addiction.
MATT RICHTEL: Unfortunately,
a lot of those stories--
and some of them
are in here-- have
to do about a car incident.
But you know what's-- I've had
my son or daughter say to me--
so you guys know this experience
to take it out of the car,
where someone's trying to talk
to you and you have your device
and you go, it's just
one thing I have to do.
You know that, right?
And you really don't.
I've had my kids, I think,
more than once say to me--
I think my son said to me,
"Hey you have kids, you know."
And I'm aware of this.
And what happens is when you're
in the moment with that device,
it is so consuming.
It's so, so terribly
consuming that you are
blind to everything around you.
And you really do feel like you
are essential at that moment.
Now I would challenge you
guys in a way I perpetually
challenge myself, always.
How urgent is that thing?
How important am I?
I always am finding
I'm way less important
than I imagine that I might be.
MALE SPEAKER: Interesting.
AUDIENCE: I have a
quick question, just
following up on the cars, then.
Because you put your
cell phone away,
but a lot of the
new-fangled cars
have a dash which is
effectively a giant cellphone.
Is that not like taking an
alcoholic, who's driving,
and installing a
keg and beer tap
in the front seat of the car?
MATT RICHTEL: Yeah, I
mean-- what's your name?
AUDIENCE: Olivier.
MATT RICHTEL: Olivier, that is
what a lot of the scientists
say today.
There is a really vibrant
conversation going on,
policy conversation
going on, around the car.
And the conversation
basically goes like this.
The car makers say, people are
going to do this stuff anyway.
Let's make it, quote, unquote,
"as safe as possible."
And the policy folks
and the safety folks
and the neuroscientists say,
you got to be kidding me.
There is no safe as possible.
There's safe and there's unsafe.
And when you look down and
when you take your eyes
off the road, even in the
case of some of the new stuff
where they project, they use
holographic, sophisticated
optics to project it
through the windshield,
even when you're looking in
the direction of the road,
you still have your focus
on, say, a notification
that says, "incoming text."
What this fits into is
this larger conversation,
Olivier, which
basically says, are
we able to draw a stark line
and modify some of our behavior,
or we just trying to
find more convenient ways
to fit it into our lives?
Right now in that junk
food conversation,
basically as a society,
we are 16-year-olds
who just discovered
$5 in our pocket
and the store on the corner
has a sale on nacho cheese.
And forget about it.
MALE SPEAKER: Really quick.
So the mic isn't
working, so we're just
going to repeat the question.
So we're talking
about a text sabbath,
or taking a sabbath from
technology for a day or more
and trying to see
there's anecdotes
of that being effective.
MATT RICHTEL: Anecdotes and
science-- just a tiny bit
of science here.
A woman from this
area at Stanford
did a terrific
study with veterans
who were suffering PTSD.
And I mentioned
this in the book.
And when they began to
do some meditation, which
is its own form of sabbath,
they became far less responsive
to bursts of
external stimulation
that might otherwise
unnerve them.
There are a bunch
of other evidence
that adds up and seems to
suggest those sabbaths do work.
You slow down your thinking.
You make a clearer decision.
You're not burning
your working memory,
that I was alluding to earlier.
They really work if you
can stick with them.
And they need not be-- I mean,
I wonder what you would say.
You do a lot of backpacking.
What happens for you
when you get away?
MALE SPEAKER: It's
interesting, because I
think towards the end of
the book, the neuroscientist
that you refer to throughout,
I think one or two of them
were talking about, they want
to find the science behind why
stepping out into
nature, the outdoors,
it actually has a
profound effect on people.
It's tough.
I wonder-- it's almost
like a reinforcing,
I guess, anecdote.
You hear so many people
talk about the outdoors
and nature being restorative.
I almost wonder if we expect
it before we get there.
You kind of have to let
yourself experience it, I think.
But I think it is the sabbath.
I think it probably,
the working memory,
these things get
to take a break.
A lot of the systems get to
stop operating at rapid pace.
MATT RICHTEL: Yeah, I don't
want to overdo the science,
but there's stuff in
here about research--
what happens, how you
learn and remember
better when you let this rest.
But anecdotally, I
will tell you someone's
called me with a story that
I'm not prepared to report yet,
because I need more evidence.
But, of a man, sleep deprived
from playing video games who
killed someone on a roadway.
And it may be a seminal
case, in the spirit of this,
who was up for 55 hours.
I'm not totally clear
on the details yet.
But other folks at Stanford talk
a ton about the costs to sleep.
And you've been seeing
this blue light stuff.
Got to say again, not a screed
against technology, just a
call to let's understand
the power of it.
Even driving-- and I can't
remember the numbers.
They're in the book.
And they might go
up to 12 seconds,
depending on what you're doing.
But when you are looking
down-- but even when you're not
looking down, if you are
focused on something else,
your brain is elsewhere.
Most of the time-- let's
take the driving context.
Let's forget about
the working contest.
Most of the time,
you get away with it.
We are actually bad
scientists in our own lives.
This is a very bad sample size.
You text and drive, you text
and drive, nothing ever happens.
You do it 100 times.
You go, 100% of the time,
nothing bad happened.
So that means nothing
bad will ever happen.
The problem is,
in those instances
where you have to
react like this--
has anybody here ever been
in a wreck due to whatever?
So do you remember how
quickly that happens?
It's almost unbelievable.
You can't even
remember what happened.
Someone comes around a corner.
It's that instant.
And I've heard some
terrible stories
in the course of reporting this.
It's that terrible,
terrible tragic instant,
when somebody comes across the
road, where someone swerves,
and you can't react.
And then those milliseconds,
let alone seconds, matter.
MALE SPEAKER: Really quick.
Somehow the mic
isn't picking it up.
It was a great question
about company culture
and if other companies have
programs or initiatives
that they've done to
try to curb this at all.
MATT RICHTEL: I'm going to
ask our British visitor.
Was it British Telecom?
There's a company
in Britain that
has no emails after 5 o'clock
at night, or maybe it's Germany.
Oh, it's a car company
in Germany, I think.
And they will say,
you just can't answer.
You can somehow be
penalized for it.
Surely someone who's watching
online will know that.
Years ago, Intel flirted
with No Email Fridays
for a group of people.
You guys have some people doing
some really interesting stuff.
I've written about
it on our front page.
Facebook, Twitter had someone
talking about meditation stuff.
The truth is-- and I'm
in this business too.
I'm a "New York Times" reporter.
When they need me, they need me.
But the reality of it
is-- and you mentioned
the self-importance piece.
I really would underscore it.
As I've reflected
a lot, I think we
tend to use this stuff much more
for our validation, escaping,
sense of importance, all
that stuff than our bosses
really need us.
So again, I'd urge
you to explore,
as I am continuing to explore--
I am far from terrific
at this-- just how
urgent it really is.
I think it oftentimes can fall
to an individual to control it,
even as much as we would
blame the external culture.
MALE SPEAKER: I want to
actually piggyback on that.
So I was thinking about
the evolutionary need
for social interaction.
You get the ping.
Is it a Facebook comment?
Is it a Like, Instagram,
Twitter, what is it?
But I'm also
thinking about FOMO.
So Fear Of Missing
Out-- a lot of people
talk about it in the Valley.
So one thing we hear
about now, as you're
sitting at the doctor's
office, you're sitting in line.
You pull out your phone.
Even if you're not on email,
you're reading new articles.
There's a certain fear, I
think, for a lot of folks
that if you're not up to
speed with the times--
and it's world events,
current events.
It's politics.
It can be just media and
fashion, all sorts of stuff,
sports.
What about that FOMO?
What about just fear of
not being in the know?
Is that an evolutionary
thing as well?
MATT RICHTEL: The short
answer is, I don't know.
May I do a longer
answer and get weird?
MALE SPEAKER: Are we
cool with getting weird?
MATT RICHTEL: Can I get weird?
MALE SPEAKER: Do I
need to step away?
MATT RICHTEL: No, no, no.
I need you to make
animal noises.
No, I'm kidding--
not that weird.
I think FOMO is an
illusion, to a large extent.
And the weird part
of this is, I'm
willing to go spiritual and
existential with you, if you
want.
And I'll do it by
way of coming back
to Reggie Shaw, the young
man who got in the accident.
Remember he had come
back from his mission?
I know Reggie very well.
This is a very,
very intimate book
with deep portrayals of
people and their thoughts--
his family, the prosecutors,
the victims' advocate,
and in particular, Reggie.
The woman that he had coupled
with that got him in trouble
wound up getting
married to someone else.
And when he was driving
that morning, even
at 6:30 in the
morning, he was having
an essentially
meaningless text exchange
with another young woman.
If I had to ask myself,
what was Reggie doing,
I think Reggie was filling
a hole at that moment.
He was really struggling.
And when I think
about FOMO, and I
think about what draws
us to our devices
all the time, I think
a lot personally
about filling moments,
about escaping,
about finding stimulation.
I mean, think of
the challenge just
of sitting in line
at the grocery store,
and you go to your device.
Think of the challenge of
sitting with someone in silence
and waiting for an
interesting conversation,
or just getting to know
the person in quiet.
Think of the
discomfort of making
quiet OK, your own moments OK.
On the scale of weird and
existential and spiritual,
I don't think these
were ever easy things.
I mean, I think that that
is an endless-- not endless,
but it's an essential part
of the human condition.
And part of what
we're doing, I think,
when we put terms on it, like,
I'm afraid of missing out,
some of that might be true if
it's pertinent to your job.
Some of it might be rather fear
of being in the moment Fee--
MALE SPEAKER: We
can trademark it.
I sense a book about
this coming up.
I sense a work of
fiction, perhaps.
Children in the car being
a lot more distracting
than a text or an email
coming in on the phone.
MATT RICHTEL: So another-- I
mentioned the spam research,
which was one of my favorites.
Another one of my favorites,
when I-- bit of trivia--
am doing this,
was, what if I have
someone in the car with me?
Isn't that also a distraction?
AUDIENCE: There's the radio.
All these things
are distracting.
MATT RICHTEL: So all
these things-- so
let's start with the passenger.
Passenger turns out to be
even a safety advantage.
Not a kid, but a passenger.
And I'll come to
kids in a second.
But a passenger says to
you, look out, it's raining.
Modulates his or her voice with
the conditions on the road,
actually acts as a proverbial
second set of eyes.
When there are teens in a
car with a teen driver, that
is a safety disadvantage,
the research shows.
I don't know when
it's an adult driver
with-- were you a teen father?
I'm just kidding.
So I don't actually know
about that piece of it.
But let's go to radio, which is
another really good question.
It turns out that now, with
being able to map the brain
and be able to do lots
of cognitive measures,
we can begin to
see the variability
of cognitive distraction
from various activities,
from the most extreme,
which is texting,
where you're looking down,
you're manually engaged,
you're cognitively engaged, to
maybe on the other end, which
is the radio.
The radio, you are, to an
extent cognitively engaged.
Less so, though, when talking
to somebody even hands-free,
because they can see through
mapping the brain how much more
of the brain gets engaged,
including the visual cortex.
Because you in your mind's
eye are picturing the person
you're talking to you.
And the act of
interacting with somebody
takes up more of the brain.
So all of these go to those
milliseconds of switching time.
Now if you're like me
and you occasionally
yell at sports talk radio,
I'm not sure where that falls.
And I should stipulate here
that road distractions have
been a problem for a long time.
Fatalities have been in
the tens of thousands
for many years, owing
to the largest extent,
from drunk driving, but
to lots of other things.
The issue here is whether this
thing has become systemic.
It's not the
occasional look away.
It's an activity that
30% of people are doing.
And that's just texting.
And 90%, 85%, say it's
completely unacceptable.
So we're talking really
in a systemic level
about orders of magnitude.
This is not the occasional
bite of a burger.
MALE SPEAKER: That's actually
an interesting thought
about the orders of magnitude.
I think when-- you mention this
was a landmark case, Reggie's
case, the first time we
think, definitely in Utah,
that somebody was on trial
for texting and driving.
And there was a question.
The science, the
research says that it
is orders of magnitude more
dangerous to text and drive.
But the question was, even
with orders of magnitude,
is it still that dangerous?
MATT RICHTEL: Does it
qualify as dangerous?
MALE SPEAKER: So what's
your take on that?
MATT RICHTEL: I can only give
you what the measures are.
The measures, by the
safety advocates--
and let's say it's texting--
this is Virginia Tech
Transportation Institute--
23 times risk of crash
or near crash.
University of Utah would
put that at six times.
They would put
talking on hands-free
at four times greater risk
of crash or near crash.
Now, you say objectively
is that a risk?
Here's how I do
the math on this.
There are in excess of 300,000
serious car crashes a year,
serious injury car
crashes in the US,
and 30,000-plus fatalities.
So you're already talking
about the most dangerous thing
you will do all day,
period, end of conversation.
So, yes.
MALE SPEAKER: I'm going to
take quick step back here.
I hadn't met you until today.
And I read this book and
I knew I'd meet you today.
And I was wondering,
I wonder if he's
going to be one of these guys
who's just like, if you ever
text and drive, you're crazy.
You're going to kill people.
It's terrible.
And meeting you, it seems
like you wrote this book less
to chastise people
for a potentially very
dangerous behavior and more
to, I guess, raise awareness,
like think about-- so why
did you take up this topic?
You've been doing it for awhile.
MATT RICHTEL: I watched my
behavior outside of the car.
I mean, you're dead right.
This is not an effort
to throw stones.
And it's actually not the way
I like to approach journalism
in general.
I think issues are complicated.
There usually
aren't conspiracies.
A lot of things grow simply
out of the human condition.
And so I watch my own
behavior with the phone
and then I watch my own behavior
in the car with the phone.
And I said to myself, lots
of things are at play here.
And what's interesting
to me about the car--
and I said this
at the beginning--
is it's the perfect
place to set this story.
Because if we can do it
under these conditions,
at 55 miles an hour in the
freezing rain when you're
a pretty decent guy who would
go to his missionary training
center president and admit
that he has to go home
with his tail between his
legs and he's a good guy,
like many of us are
good people, then
what does it say about us
under other circumstances?
So to me, this is an act
for myself, for others,
to try to understand,
what is this thing?
I think it's fair to say--
I've heard this said,
and I don't know that I can
prove it with numbers to you
today.
But the phone is the most
quickly adopted technology
in all of human history, by
far faster than the book.
When that happens, that's not
because Motorola and Apple
and Verizon tell you to get it.
There's no shortage of companies
in this country telling
you to buy everything.
And most of us buy none of it.
But many of us have two phones.
That is not an accident.
That's not marketing.
That goes to utility, power,
and when it's that big, to me
it goes to the fact that it hits
at social, primitive wiring.
And that's what I try
to explicate here.
MALE SPEAKER: Wonderful.
My last question-- thank you
for that-- last one for me.
So one thing you do
great in this book,
among other things, the
data and everything,
is you really get into
the stories behind a lot
of the key players in the book.
And I was really
surprised towards the end.
I don't want to betray
too much for those
who are going to read it soon.
You talk about the importance
of telling the truth.
And that was a really
powerful, I think,
one or two chapters for me.
And I'm curious.
It almost seemed--
I almost wondered
why you had those chapters.
You build it up so well, here's
what the value of the truth is.
Was it a reminder
that we all need
to tell the truth to ourselves
about our technology use?
Why did you talk
about the truth?
MATT RICHTEL: Yes
is the short answer.
I mean, at the end of this
book, partly, very nakedly,
it was the publisher saying,
so what do we do about this?
And I didn't want to write a
book that was a "how-to" book.
And they knew that well.
I believe more than
anything-- sorry.
Pull back.
"I believe" is not the
right sentence there.
I love the tell stories.
I think it's just
a personal passion.
And I love to
captivate myself as I'm
doing the task and the
reader who is listening.
That is a very connected
experience for me.
So I didn't want this book to
suddenly go into a manifesto.
The publisher wanted something.
And I tried to
find the line where
I could stay in the
spirit of this book,
but also explain what happened
here that led to change.
Because as you'll see
if you read this book,
that a remarkable thing happened
at the end of this story.
And I'm not going to give
it away-- a truly remarkable
transformation happened
with this character,
like no other I've
ever witnessed
in fiction or real life.
And it came from someone
confronting himself.
And I went and talked to
people about the challenge
of doing that, because I think
it lies at the heart of this.
And all the time in my
relationship with my device,
as I began this thing, talking
about your relationship
with the device,
I have to confront
that relationship and all
the things it represents.
If my wife says, did
you take out the trash,
and I suddenly find myself
checking the Giants' score
seconds later, I ask myself,
why did I just go do that?
And naturally, the answer is,
because the Giants need me.
It's probably
because I'm escaping
from a moment of whatever
it is-- irritability,
didn't she ask me
that-- something human.
So I'm trying to find the
ways in which my device gets
in the way of truth.
And I'm sorry to be so
long-winded from lunch.
I can't help myself.
I want to thank you
guys for coming.
I really, really
genuinely appreciate it.
MALE SPEAKER: Well, thanks
for being here as well, Matt.
[APPLAUSE]